demandez un panier un acte délicat
devenue malheureusement habituelle pour
certains étudiants comme kim dung pas
trop de travail pas trop de rouleaux et
on ne peut pas dépenser pour la vie au
quotidien lors bas il ya des produits
donc au traditionnel des produits secs
comme du café du riz des légumes des
biscuits l'ordre régional des experts
comptables à l'initiative de cette
distribution a récolté 14 mille euros de
dons la collecte elle s'est fait au sein
des cabinets c'est à la fois des
collaborateurs qui sont venus pour pour
aider à donner pour les étudiants les
plus démunis
c'est également des clients parce que
voilà il ya certains il ya certains
cabinets qui ont qu'ils ont
lancer l'opération sur leurs réseaux
sociaux etc ce jour-là il y a eu plus de
demandes que deux paniers disponibles
alors on a de nouveaux étudiants
effectivement chaque jour depuis le
début du confinement en plus c'est vrai
que ça a été compliqué parce que nous
avons tenu une permanence étudiante donc
les soirs au secours populaire depuis
trois ans avec les restrictions
sanitaires dont on n'a pas pu la faire
donc ils venaient plus sur nos genre
d'ouverture traditionnelle et donc
certains ne pouvaient pas venir en
fonction de leurs heures de cours
beaucoup d'étudiants viennent chercher
un panier pour la première fois c'est le
cas de mathieu cet étudiant en
alternance percevait un salaire chaque
mois
mais au chômage partiel depuis plusieurs
semaines mathieu doit faire attention à
son budget bah c'est une des contraintes
surtout quand on va faire les courses on
sait qu'elle va là où il faut quand même
ses limites et on joue pas c'est pas
qu'on veut pas prendre tout ce qu'on
veut mais on fait attention prix on fait
alors on fait beaucoup plus attention
que d'habitude
la situation des jeunes s'est dégradée
en raison de la crise sanitaire
d'après une enquête un étudiant sur deux
ne mange pas à sa faim en france